most people are half-hearted
half-interested half-engaged in their
actual dream and actual ambition
self-perception should always have a
component of self-evaluation
compared to where you want to be when
you are in silence in a way in which you
are suffering because of fear
you are not going to be able to serve
need motivation watch the top 10 of
believe nation because i love it
all my life
hey it's evan carmichael and i make
these videos because you are probably
the most ambitious person in your circle
but you know you're capable of more and
you get that push by surrounding
yourself with the best
so today let's learn from one of the
best brendan burchard and my take on his
top 10 rules for success
enjoy okay let's kick it off with rule
number one own your ambition
most people are half-hearted
half-interested half-engaged
in their actual dream and actual
ambition because they either fear it or
they feel insecure or incapable
and teaching people i literally just had
this conversation with one of the most
successful people
in literally the like the world in the
top .001
category of revenue is has not
fully expressed and owned their ambition
instead people apologize for their
ambition
hide their ambition you have to learn to
own your ambition
speak of the ambition chase the ambition
drive the ambition
and lead the ambition it is a full both
allowance
back to the words allowance of the
ambition and an active generation
of that ambition the further you are
from your ambitions the more miserable
you are
and most people don't look at their
goals every day so no wonder we have a
world that says i'm disconnected
it's like wake up like i asked people
did you look at your goals today
that's just simply that's literally
personal development 101 is
have goals look at them most people do
not do that
i want you to not just not go i want you
to deeply visualize feel
sense and talk about your ambitions way
more
like way more like i love that about you
you're like i'm gonna build the freaking
disney that's nonsense
and everybody around you knows it you
know how rare that is
that's one reason i love you i i people
who are
scared to communicate about their
ambitions are cheating themselves in the
world from supporting them
i coached an olympian i love this it's
in hyperforms happens i wrote
really briefly about it but she had won
several world
records and world championships but
never
uh a medal and this was a big goal for
her and then she did and i was working
with her and then afterwards we were
having this conversation i said
what made the difference she says you
know what one day
it wasn't training it wasn't nutrition
it wasn't diet it wasn't everything we
talked about she was
one day i just i just started shouting
from the rooftops that i wanted to win a
gold medal
i started telling everybody around me
and she had this great
she says when you shout from the rooftop
what you want
two things happen one the village idiots
come out and judge you
all the village idiots she says but also
the village leaders come out go
see this let's let's set this person up
she said all of a sudden
the right coaches the the right
dietitians the right
former gold medalist the right teammates
started came out and all of a sudden she
had
a community who were galvanizing behind
this vision and ambition she had
that she'd never achieved even though
nothing changed in her physical body
it was like she communicated the
ambition
the tribe arrived the goal was achieved
complete game changer
rule number two be decisive one of the
higher performers in the world
jeff bezos he started a little company
called amazon tiny
he talks about this idea that he an
executive team
makes decisions when they have about 60
percent of the information
so i'm 10 percent above jeff bezos yeah
i should
yeah actually think about that for a
minute like wait a minute
a person and a team that could get all
the information in the world
they what they do is they're moving
forward even when they don't have
everything and what perfectionists do
what they don't realize is there's a
difference between perfection remember
perfection is
to perfect in motion iterative moving
it's active
what they also can't admit sometimes is
the real struggle is they're indecisive
most perfectionists they actually know
the next moves and i'm like go
swat team make it happen release it drop
it do it
go and i'm cheering them on i'm like go
like for everyone listening
you need to know high performers are
decisive not because they are like
i know everything and i've got clarity i
know
they know if they don't drop it if they
don't release it if they don't do it
they can't iterate and make it better
they can't learn just as you said
and worse they can't be of service
because when you're in silence in your
life and you're in silence because of
fear in your life
not silence like the way you and i talk
about in a positive way being still and
silent inside that's a positive thing
but when you are in silence in a way in
which you are suffering because of fear
you are not going to be able to serve
you you have to be in motion to serve
you have to
release things to perfect it you've got
to be decisive
almost everybody listening i did this
course with oprah winfrey network called
your next bold move
and that language of being bolder
everybody listening probably should do
that rule number three
have deep appreciation for life when you
have real reverence for life
when you have a deep gratitude and
appreciation i like a deep gratitude
an appreciation for life
you don't hold on to a lot of yesterdays
you notice the changing fault colors now
you notice the free space that you have
now
you notice the time and the choices
and the opportunities available to you
now yesterday's not such a big deal
you don't hold the baggage and here's
how you know if you're
holding baggage you know in your heart
there's baggage there
when you keep playing small when you
keep minimizing yourself
to other people in your current
situation that's because the self's
showing up
is a self lug in the baggage feeling bad
about themselves letting it weigh down
when you're free and spirited in this
moment when you're truly present
free from yesterday like when you're
present right here
that authenticity that spirit shines
through and
listen the same people who completely
shut you down yesterday
when they go to shut you down today you
go hey that's not okay
maybe the old you let them shut you down
the new you today you
the old you let them shut you down
because you had hurts and
feelings and old stories and you labeled
yourself differently and you let
yourself be put in your place by
somebody
today the place you've been put on is a
fresh ground of earth
today the place that you've been put in
is this moment
and this moment doesn't reek of
yesterday
when the sun set yesterday it set when
the sun
rose this morning it was fresh there
were new birds around your house not old
birds they moved on too
you got to kind of get it in your mind
at some point that this day
if you have real reverence for life you
don't meet the day
as you did in high school because if you
have reverence for life you recognize
that all those struggles brought you
here
that all those struggles were necessary
to make a new you a fresh you
that you gotta release some of those
hurts man
and those pains girl and those stories
my friends
because they're old and how can you
possibly touch the roo
just touch the rim of your potential of
the future
how are you going to get lift to be able
to leap up there and grab it
when you got 40 pounds of old stories of
stupid stuff you did in high school
or the way they treated you when you're
10 or the way they talked to you when
you were 30
like you're in a different place now and
you need to be in this place light on
your feet
because how many of you think like the
truth is right now
you need to be able to adapt i mean the
world's in chaos
you need to be light on your feet right
like if you've ever taken dance classes
before
when you're heavy on your feet it's
because your body moves in the old ways
the more you learn to be present in the
moment the more you get light on your
feet
and all of a sudden now when your
partner turns this way boom you can go
that way because you're not thinking
about the way
you went 100 times ago you're there with
that person dancing
and now it's real it's alive and you're
creating something new and unique
between you
you need to do that with the moment like
now
like the chaos of the world and the
abundance of the world
and the opportunities of the world have
never been intersecting the way that
they are right now
rule number four define yourself have
you ever had the pain point where you
perceive yourself
different than everybody else around you
you know you think you're this great
amazing person and other people around
you you're being mean
or maybe sometimes you're like down on
yourself and everyone's like no you're
awesome i love you what's wrong
i love you if you ever had that it's
like there's this
challenge sometimes between our
self-perception and how other people
perceive us so the first thing you have
to do is make sure
every single day that you have a very
clear
intention for who you want to be i know
you've been watching my youtube
hopefully for a long time and you hear
me talk about this
you can't keep bumbling and each day and
just reacting all day
you have to have an intention for like
what kind of person do i want to show up
to the world
as like how do i want to be perceived
and be really clear about that don't
just like
wander into social situations all
throughout high school all throughout
college all throughout your professional
life
showing up as you do normally instead go
how do i really want to be in this
situation
how do i want to feel in the situation
how do i want to treat
people in this situation how do i want
other people to perceive
me not in some kind of method of
conformity
but rather like what's the real mean if
you can't articulate
the real you please don't ask other
people to figure it out
if you're not clear about your own
values
how you want the world to see you and
what you want to accomplish
please don't ask the world to know
who you are and what you're about so it
begins with that intention that clarity
of self-first you got to do the homework
you got to do the personal development
you got to read the books you got to
geek out and figure out your values your
drives how you want to show up to people
what your goals are
because if you don't know it i promise
you we're never going to figure it out
and i think a lot of people are really
miserable in their life because they're
like no one understands
me but they don't understand themselves
or
they don't understand themselves and
communicate who they are
so it all begins with intention all
becomes with clarity you got to start by
defining yourself
and every day look at it i mean like
literally every day like
what are the words that should define
how you're going to be today i have
people write that down every single day
like i want to be a person who is and
write it out
i want to treat other people like this
because if every day you show up as that
person and you treat people like this
then integrity starts happening in your
life you have that congruence of being
who you really want to be
and more people see you on a consistent
basis being like
you versus scatter shock just reacting
or conforming
or trying to fit in now when you know
you and you show up as you more often
they go
i get you my friend evan carmichael's
book listen
humans are built to serve some people
are built to serve the world
others want to serve the 25 people
closest to them
but in either case humans are built to
serve so if you're not happy right now
it's because you're not serving enough
you got to pick up this book because
it's so inspiring to remind you that
we're all here to contribute
to make a difference to make an impact
and this is your field guide for that
rule number five track your habits you
have to have
daily intention and habit tracking
you you can't leave your personal
development to randomness
and what most people do they leave their
personal growth to randomness
and so they're always in a land of
mediocrity you
have to have that morning routine and
that evening routine
of evaluating where you are and where
you want to go and
asking the hard questions of what is it
about me that's not moving forward what
is it about me that i need to accept
love care for take care of do a better
job with
how do i treat other people so i can get
ahead faster what do i need to focus on
if you don't do that on a daily basis
you're going through the motions and
even if you're successful imagine how
much more successful you would be
if you were way more intentional and you
actually tracked
your habits this is why we developed a
high performance planner because
i i wanted it i was like i know how easy
it is to go through a day you hustle all
day
and you crash at the end of the day i
know the hundred hour work weeks i know
how that feels i know what that's about
but if you're doing all that and you're
not aware
that leads to a nightmare that leads to
you take the wrong path and you're
hustling down the wrong path you lean
the ladder against the wrong building
you do the wrong thing
the awareness on the daily is something
people need to build into a routine and
physicalize like write not a note on
your phone a journal
workbook planner something that you
actually connect pen to paper
you think through and if we can get you
ambition clarified ambition
speak the ambition own the ambition and
you're actually intentionally tracking
each day you win this game
rule number six ask for help being bold
is asking sometimes
not just taking some huge action it's
asking for help i wish as a 19 year old
kid i could look back and say hey kid
man
you're going to kill yourself ask
someone for help
tell someone what's going on your head
raise your hand
like admit it be vulnerable and i didn't
i didn't know that that would have been
bold
i've been bold been vulnerable and i saw
it bold doesn't have to be
swat team take down the world sometimes
ask for help
put yourself out there and know you'll
figure out you'll catch that clip you'll
figure it out
you'll get it going on you'll improve
but move
rule number seven do progress checks
make sure that you're doing
progress checks i know a lot of people
who feel like you know what i'm amazing
i get a lot done i'm
awesome and yet they are still living in
their parents house and they're 50.
you know a lot of people self-perception
isn't real because their self-perception
is never checked against progress
self-perception should always have a
component of self-evaluation
compared to where you want to be because
a lot of people think they're great but
they haven't done anything in seven
weeks
a lot of people think they're also not
good but they're also
they've had so much progress they're not
giving themselves credit we got a lot of
people who are so
amazing in their life but they never
feel amazing because
all the progress they get they never
look at it and they never
integrate those wins integrate that
progress integrate that momentum
and so their identity feels weak they
feel bad about themselves they hate
themselves
even though they're amazing and
sometimes we have to tie a little bit of
our perception
to our progress because that just makes
it real
i know people comment and go oh you
don't understand brandon that's
dangerous thing to do because some
people
if they're not getting any progress
they'll hate themselves no this is about
hating yourself it's about being real
with yourself
like if you're not progressing towards
your goals call spay to spade be like
you know what
i'm not showing up enough i'm not giving
my full
i'm not like playing intensely i'm not
protecting my time and handling my time
well i'm not speaking up for my truth
sometimes you got to be real with
yourself before you know yourself
sometimes you got to acknowledge the
fact that you're not progressing
and that will spark something and you go
you know what i don't want to feel
like a loser i don't want to feel like
i'm not doing things and i know that
language is hard for people because no
one wants to feel like a loser and no
one wants to feel like they're not doing
anything
but sometimes it's okay i mean there's
times in my life when
i want to be a writer and i mean you
guys know i've written six bestselling
books now
but i'm telling you before that period
of time i kind of hated myself because
the truth was
i wanted to be a writer but i wasn't
writing and at some point i had to own
that and go
you know what it's okay i feel crappy
about myself as a writer because i'm not
riding
and that internal angst can sometimes
become fuel and fire
the main thing is don't let the internal
angst stop you and hate yourself
instead acknowledge it is real call a
spade a spade
and get back in there and improve
approach your life
as an opportunity to grow and progress
faster
and your self perception will start to
align with it like your
self-perception your confidence how you
feel about yourself if you can align it
with real progress you'll feel momentum
and the depth of your character if you
have the bad days or the bad weeks or
the bad months
you gotta acknowledge it and be okay
with it don't hate yourself but go
i can do better what's my next project
what's my next
progress checkpoint what's the next
milestone
and get back on track again and you'll
find yourself feeling better and people
perceiving you
in more of your truth which is a capable
competent confident person rule number
eight
share the highest performing people in
the world are courageous
but the way that they practice that
courage is in a very simple
elegant way they share their true
thoughts feelings needs desires
requests with others more often than
underperformers
underperformers kind of keep it all in
they're embarrassed about what they want
they fear judgment so they don't share
and if they share and they get judgment
or push back they shut down
where high performers they share they
also get judgment and push back
but they keep going and that's a
critical difference of success
in life so i'm encouraging you in 2019
to be more open more consistent more
honest more courageous and sharing
what's up what do you want what do you
need this year where could you some help
what are those big ambitions what's that
big mountain you want to climb that
other people might make fun of you for
doing
if you're not sharing that with the
immediate people around you
including your spouse your partner's
significant other your wife your husband
your family the kids then what's up with
that silence
rule number nine be generous here's
what's beautiful about high performance
this is really important
there's success but in the way we
measured high performance high
performance means
you succeed beyond standard norms
over the long term while maintaining
well-being and positive relationships
that's the hardest part that's the
hardest part that's why i love your
podcast
because so much of what you come back to
is relationships but high performers
don't burn out relationships they don't
take people for granted
in fact you know it's like booker t
washington taught us you know there's
two ways to exert strength one is
pushing down
the other is pulling up and high
performers they're the pulling up kind
that's why high performers also don't
report being lonely at the top
one of my mentors brian tracy said if
you're lonely at the top you did it
wrong
but high performance because you're
lifting people up it's almost like
you have a chorus of people right you
got a tribe you lifted people up along
you were generous with people as euros
and that's what that our research what
became so famous about iforum's habits
was
we could measurably prove long-term
success and say
wait you can have long-term success and
maintain your health and your
relationships that's possible
because most people think you have to
compromise you got to become a jerk
or you can't work out yeah you can't be
married or you can't have a long-term
relationship you can't have kids
will you tell ourselves these stupid
stories and rule number 10 the last
homie for a very special bonus clip
is ask for feedback let's say you got a
job
and you have a great meeting and you
feel good about the meeting lots of
people walk out and just go celebrate
and they'll go
i guess i did a great job instead ask
other people like how did that meeting
go for you
how do you think i did was there
anything else i could do better
how do you think of the way i talk to
this person is there anything that you
feel like i missed
and just start asking other people to
share the perceptions of you
and your performance it is the gutsiest
scariest thing in the world for people
to do because most people don't want
feedback
but if you never solicit feedback if
you're
not consistent and asking for it then
people just don't say it and then one
day they're like well i think you're
like this and you're like
how could you say that we've been in a
relationship for 10 years
and they're like i guess you never asked
so you got to ask
ask consistently and constantly in
almost everything you do
be like how is that did i come across as
this i was trying to go for that
did it work i mean even as we're
shooting this video you know today i
shot a couple of these
and i asked my team i'm like do you
think that was like too slow
was it too fast did i get my points
across
because if you don't ask that you don't
know and a lot of the external feedback
that comes
from others can give you the real
direction for how to be better
i know it's scary i know it's like well
people might say negative things but if
you realize
all you're trying to do is learn not
judge
everything goes fine if all you're
trying to do is say hey just give me the
honest feedback and don't worry about
saying it exactly right i won't get
hooked i won't get mad
you gotta actually have those
conversations with people allow them to
share the feedback
and don't take it personally take it as
a learning point that either applies and
is true for you or not
like i get a lot of feedback i'm like i
don't agree with that that's not true
i don't think that's true for me i'll
try to do better next time to make sure
that that doesn't happen
but i don't ever hold it against other
people now is it true that some people
are going to be mean to you
is it true some people are going to call
you names it's true some people are
going to be hard on you
yeah that's part of life so don't be
surprised by it anymore
you're too old now to be surprised by
other people being a jerk to you
you should know that it's going to
happen you should know people are going
to give you negative feedback
and what you have to do is start
learning to take feedback from people
who know how to deliver it
if someone gives terrible feedback and
they're a terrible jerk and they're
always that way
man don't take that personally just know
that's their style that's their thing
that's their life
that's their you know axe to grind not
yours
you want to find the people in your life
who know how to give
good feedback and you want to ask them
for more of it
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the question of the
day
i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video and
your plan
of action for the next week when you
watch something and get motivated
and just get inspired you have a 35
chance of actually following through but
when you get
motivated and then you actually create
an action plan for what you're gonna do
you increase it from 35 to 91
chance of you actually following through
and when you share your plan publicly
that jumps to 95 chance of following
through so i want that for you
i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week
put it down in the comments below so i
can celebrate
you go have meetups with your customers
go have scheduled time to sit down with
real-life customers
to talk about their experience how your
product helps them
what they think of your brand what they
think of your message what they think of
you
because what happens is a lot of times
especially in this world the real
engagement that influencers or people
celebrity or
big businesses have is here and you know
they're talking
they're dm'ing they're looking at the
comments you know they're replying to
the emails
but this is no substitute for someone
looking you in the eye and saying hey
thank you for creating that product
thank you for all the team
and all the work and all the things i
don't even know about that must take
for you to make the difference in the
world because there's not just
validation there which is nice
there's real connection there and you'll
learn a lot
you know i have customers telling me
about things that products and programs
we put out five six seven years ago and
they're really excited about and they're
like are you gonna bring that back
or hey you know what i have this one
thing i mean part of
the the genesis of the high performance
planner this is what i used in my life
to organize my life and to organize me
and
it was something that i've been doing
for years and years and years
i didn't really have the full vision of
doing it the way that we
ultimately launched it until i talked to
you know a curvilion people who had read
this
and we're looking to operationalize you
know the mindsets and habits
that successful people have and it
really
put a fire under my butt i was i was
kind of kind of put this off
a little bit more to finish another
project but i talked to so many people
who had this
that made me launch this early and on
time
if you want more top 10 videos they're
not on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel
just for it go check it out the link is
right there next to me
continue to believe and i'll see you
there